hier lundi 4 octobre 2021 alors qu il
est 10h30 au mexique
et 17h30 en france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la nouvelle est tombée panne géante
mondial c'est l'information de la soirée
qui touche à la fois facebook mais aussi
instagram whatsapp messenger et autant
vous dire que cette information a créé
la panique c'était le cas où c'était un
peu la panique
c'est énorme ce qui se passe
et oui facebook instagram et whatsapp
nous ont lâchés les 103 5 milliards
d'utilisateurs désespéré sur le carreau
emmerdes du coup certains ont tenté de
trouver une explication logique à ce
problème comme nabila il se passe un
truc étrange je pense qu'on est envahi
par les aliens omagad mais bon
heureusement qu anthony morel de bfm
business était là pour tout clarifier
plus de six heures de black out total
l'ensemble de l'écosystème doute la
galaxie de services problème de
configuration des serveurs en gros c'est
un problème lié à ce qu'on appelle les
dns bref les influenceurs n'ont pas pu
influencer hier soir et ont donc
sûrement perdu l'oseille mais forcément
moins que mark zuckerberg qui a laissé
six milliards de dollars dans cette
crise et en plus qui a dû utiliser son
rival twitter pour s'excuser enfin la
ronde quoi oui il est allé sur twitter
pour s'excuser il pouvait pas s'excuser
sur facebook ça marchait pas bon on
s'est couchés inquiète de ne plus jamais
pouvoir les quais des photos de petits
chatons sur instagram mais au réveil
tout est réparé et on a pu enfin admirer
le fils de benjamin castaldi donné ses
plus belles astuces pour faire de beaux
pancake le jour auront fred épingle
aussi rond a accueilli hier est bas les
poules auront des dents
[Musique]
sitôt l'affairé tourne water doublé leur
et spécialiste des réseaux sociaux
qu'est ce qui s'est passé hier soir
c'est un truc de fou
ouais j'ai envie de vous dire je ne sais
pas il ya peut-être la moitié d'internet
qui c'est qui s'est coupé hier c'est la
première fois que ça arrive surtout si
longtemps parce qu'on a déjà vu des
coupures de facebook mais pendant six ou
sept heures c'est la première fois et
franchement il y en hier en allant nous
coucher personne ne savait ce qu'il en
était on a tous flipper un flipper bon
moi je m'en fous un peu mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des gens ils se sont arrêtés de
vivre c'est incroyable pourquoi les
quatre plateformes facebook messenger
instagram whatsapp ont planté en même
temps eh bien ça alors ça c'est une très
bonne question tous
non mais c'est une question c'est une
bonne question parce que les gens ne le
savent pas bah oui facebook
whatsapp messenger et instagram c'est la
même plateforme a racheté il ya quelques
temps instagram et what's app et ils ont
mutualisé tous les serveurs et ou sousse
et tous au même endroit voilà je vous
écris certains sont anti facebook mais
pas anti whatsapp c'est une grosse
bêtise
c'est ça
c'est vraiment planqué dans les pays
scandinaves la tolérer oui non je suis
pas bien sûr c'est plutôt planqué aux
etats unis c'est maman m'a dit pays
scandinaves à cause du froid parce que
ça fait chauffer dans ces picard
serrures
et ce côté là c'est un support
allez venez deux là les deux vieux j'en
peux plus a rigolé non mais l'autre bout
du monde
on reçoit des personnages
sont comme des fous ou quoi mais aussi
maria isabel par laboeuf deux mois que
les scores les toits sur les rénos art
truc de fou vous avez vu qu'il ya eu
sans rigoler pas chez ta mère non mais
sans déconner à excuser les thomas alors
non mais ceux ci disent que ce que vous
dites est paré oui mais qu'il a eue le
dire de
nom mais ce qui est vrai mais ce que je
sais pas s'il aurait menti dans le monde
à voir ce qu'on dit ned - fais pas chier
pourquoi pourquoi excuse moi un combat
vous allez apprendre le ton de
l'émission
dit les choses tu sais on dit les choses
pourquoi ça ni si longtemps revenir
alors ça c'est la grande question voilà
alors non mais on sait moi je me suis
demandé si ce n'était pas une attaque
une cyberattaque alors il n'y a aucune
hypothèse sérieuse sur le sujet donc
faut pas non plus s'enflammer mais enfin
c'est quand même bizarre alors ce que
dit facebook c'est que ils ont supprimé
l'ensemble des routes en fait virtuelle
qui mène au serveur facebook se rappelle
l'adressage moi je veux pas vous
fatiguer les travaux compliqué ils ont
supprimé tous donc en fait y'a même des
schémas sur internet et en adresse tous
supprimés adresse postale ou bien un
adressage donc celle adressée ce à
l'adresse des serveurs et dresse les
routes ont été supprimés ce qu'ils
pensent qu'ils juste hallucinant mais
pourquoi on sait pas les années d'un
côté
[Applaudissements]
franck anne hidalgo et là dessous les
gages aux chocs
et c'est encore sur minitel
puisque vous dit effectivement que y'a
pas de raison peut-être officiel qu'il y
aurait eu une cyber attaque mais en même
temps on se dit pourquoi pas associer
soeur pour les gens qui nous regardent
et qui peut-être flip est ce qu'on
aurait pu peut-être pendant ce laps de
temps où il ya eu ce blackout siphonner
des données comme nos numéros de carte
bleue ou est-ce qu'il faut changer nos
fatwas c'est que d'être un des codes
secrets des choses comme ça alors
franchement et je veux dire c'est
mondiale le mais les mecs mine de rien
ça va vous s'arrêtera à n'être pas une
priorité qui va dire tiens je vais
mettre que ce book
maintenant une priorité même match mais
peut-être aux états unis mon ami me dire
aller la rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
si zemmour
et moi thomas
d'abord pour répondre à mathieu
franchement je non seulement elle est
peut-être aux états unis mais c'est
certain
excellent mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que la propriété de vos photos elles ne
venaient plus la vôtre vous inscrivez
sur facebook vous donner tous à facebook
donc vous rigoliez sur wat ça parce que
c'est watsa c'est la même chose c'est la
même chose
la même chose
de ses plateformes c'est la honte de vos
données mais ouais c'est pas autre chose
ces gens là ne vivent que pour ça donc
ils ont des photos là actuellement toute
chose au mini kiki
une des photos compost nous tous par
exemple il voue le public et les
téléspectateurs sur instagram y
appartiennent à facebook non
droit de les utiliser si ils font des
publicités par exemple quand ils montent
leurs normes alger publicitaire il passé
sur la fonction peluches et non mais
non sur une pub et vous dites c'est
normal ils vous ont pas demandé les
exploitera la lettre x suite batterie
d'avocats
mais pour être ça justement le principe
de whatsapp c'est justement c'est un des
jeux pas commencer un chiffrement gilles
à la réunion on peut rien faire au
niveau des photos et tout ça c'est moi
c'est un peu différent à damas experts
parce que sur what's app oui ce facebook
en fait vous protège ce qu'on appelle le
chiffrement de bout en bout ça veut dire
ça vous protège à partir de votre
communication jusqu'à jusqu'à votre
destinataire et ça que ça vous protège
donc ça vous protège de l'extérieur mais
pas de facebook jamais parce que les
clés chez les clés de chiffrement ce qui
vous comme une clé de serrure c est
stocké chez fayard c'est peanuts ça ça
c'est pas de la sécurité pour répondre à
une question sur les utilisateurs parce
que ça c'est une question importante
merci est-ce que vos données nos données
en moi non parce que moi j'ai supprimé
tous mes comptes depuis bien longtemps
et c'est pourquoi pour ça c'est
important parce que car ces scènes
supprimées que ses comptes c'est qu'ils
sont otages non seulement je suis
peut-être spécialistes on verra mais
c'est en tout cas moi ça fait dix ans
que je me bats pour créer des
alternatives une alternative française
européenne contre ces monopoles qui sont
alors justement on arrête un projet avec
booba parce que vous avez vu sur un sky
est arrivé j'aimerais vous conseiller de
regarder ou barrière des snle cyril hahn
là c'est le moment de lancer de bagram
appelle moi je suis bouillant
et je suis vraiment chaud bouillant ça
arrive à 1 c'est plus rare voilà deux
ans et je me dis que j'étais bouillon
non mais c'est vrai donc on n en suis
pas je suis pas complètement à ce qu'il
ait ça peut être sérieux allez les
utilisateurs bon leurs données sans
protéger globalement par facebook mais à
l'insu de facebook de toute façon le
grand problème de sécurité conca tout le
monde sait les mots de passe tout le
monde met des mots de passe faciles bien
tu as mêmes pour tous vous avez le même
mot de passe pour la boîte email pour le
compte fait ça quoi que ce soit donc en
fait il suffit qu'il ya facebook peut
être sécurisé mais que votre je sais pas
vous êtes inscrit sur un vieux forum
vous avez mis le maître mot de passe les
pirates qui vont attaquer la et essai en
permanence 5 songeait toujours très
émotive à cette fois 10 et aitziber rapt
a toujours le même mot de passe donc
qu'est ce qu'il
me dit un mot de passe rabouli la porte
des lilas
mais partout rabouli la porte des lilas
à la wii nous faut
poser des questions quand on vous lit
les mots de passe régulièrement il faut
non seulement les changer un petit peu
régulièrement mais surtout mettre des
mots là bas les gens retrouvent à wemmel
pas même des phrases il faut mettre des
phrases voir des trucs avec des femelles
les banques à appliquer tout ça ça ne
sert à rien il faut mettre des phrases
vous savez une phrase molière marqueurs
ou une phrase de booba parquet vous la
mettez voilà non il vous demande sans
arrêt des signes de rajouter mais ça
c'est des ballounes
credo du culte et de sol béni
qui galèrent spécialiste
mondial comme ça qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est une enquête qui est ouverte la
halle enquête il s'est avéré que il ya
des choses un petit peu suspecte qui se
sont passées mondialement avec tout ce
qui frappe dans le monde en ce moment
donc c'est vrai que là on a privilégié
le fait de faire l' enquête même si on
pouvait tout remettre en activité
comment on peut mettre leur lancée les
gens dans le truc et se dit qu'on
n'avait pas réglé tous les problèmes
c'est sa famille un peu plus de temps
que d'habitude c'est que la halle
enquête a été un peu plus poussé
réponse
c'est une thèse c'est une timide
embellie revient comme
ça mais c'est vrai c'est ce qu'a dit oui
c'est une thèse c'est une thèse as une
ride je viens ici n'est ce pas là la
beauté érigée je suis votre obligé je
vais pas critiquer les questions
non mais c'est une connerie ça quelles
sont les choses qui ont été dites y'a
des trucs du genre patient c'est bizarre
sur les enquêtes à ce niveau là y'a
jamais denquête parce que c'est les
techniciens qui travaillent dans les
techniciens chez facebook je sais pas si
vous avez vu ça dans le figaro hier soir
ils vous ne pouvait même plus badgés
dans leur bureau ou parce qu'ils
utilisent eux-mêmes facebook que ça va
très loin qu'il ya une enquête a été
ouverte à ce alors il ya nabila va être
ma bile aldi l a10 passe un truc étrange
je pense qu'on est envahi par les aliens
oh my god
mais bien parce que et un espace un truc
étrange ou pas du tout bois il se passe
ce qui devrait se passer enfin ça se
passera un jour et facebook mais enfin
c'est normal on pense que ces géants qui
se sont bâti en quelques années
seulement sont extrêmement solides moi
je je suis persuadé que l'on déjà en
papier trop vite notre pied d'argile
est assez vite la thèse de la
cyberattaque pdg mark zuckerberg ce
matin il a perdu 7 milliards donc si on
voulait le tactile est plus riche que
toi c'est sûr mais on regagnera 15 ouais
mais si on voulait le fragiliser quand
même c'était la bonne chose a lancé une
cyberattaque ça ça semble quand même
beaucoup et prendre un temps il a les
meilleurs hackers du monde fin mai ceci
dit je n'écarte pas la thèse mais je
veux certainement pas aller dans cette
idée de complot de dire assez sûrement
saillant parce que c'est peu probable
c'est peu probable mais c'est quand même
ouvert il ya plein d'argent ce qui fait
douter quand même ah oui c'est la
longueur delà de ça oui ça veut dire
qu'ils ont été en difficulté pour
remonter quelque chose ça rend
probablement quand compris rapidement et
qui n'ont peut-être pas ce pull remonter
c'est peut-être ça se faisait en même
temps aime honnêtement je vais rester à
l'as pas très prudents sur ce cas la
raison qui sait quoi thomas la famille
et le col à pannecé je vous dis c adre
allez je vais prendre une image vous
êtes à paris dans le xvième voulait
aller dans le viiième j'en sais rien
prenez vos widz way pardon il faut pas
citer des gps sacoor vous avez la route
et vous imaginez wales a plus de route
ils ont en fait les routes d'internet
les routes d'internet
facebook commence à être plus aucune et
ça je ne sais pas donc il essaie de la
configuration similaire une attaque jean
sala non mais si oui c'est possible mais
mais pour moi ce n'est pas l'hypothèse
privilégiée l'hypothèse privilégiée
c'est un manque de sérieux dans les
configurations dans les choses
techniques très technique c'est l'erreur
humaine c'est
matthieu delormeau alors pour monsieur
c'est une erreur sachez qu'aux états
unis dans la presse et la chute sérieux
pour ils prennent ça extrêmement sérieux
sur fergie site de canal sans dessus
parce que ce qui est grave c'est pas
qu'il une panne c'est qu'on ne trouve
pas à l'origine de la page à quand on
trouve pas à l'origine de la panne c'est
grave et pour eux et aux etats unis une
cyberattaque qui sont à fond tellement
ils donnent pas une peur panique depuis
le 11 septembre du terrorisme et pour
eux c'est beaucoup plus grave une simple
panne mais pas c'est pas un moteur qui
tombe en panne c'est le monde y en a qui
ont été arrêtés pendant c'est ça c'est
ça qui est fou c'est qu'on voit que le
monde peut s'arrêter ben ouais j'ai un
copain à moi il ya ça m'a fallu envoyer
il faut qu'on parle sur what's app une
minute avant la panne il n'a jamais eu
c'est pas je voulais te dire je pars
avec un autre mec non mais je vous le
dis oui non mais vous dites que le bug a
été très long 7 heures mais en même
temps ça peut être très court aussi
c'est à dire qu'ils ont imaginé un bug
qui dure 10 jours ou un mois à gaza
devient en fait les gaffes à ce n'est
pas une bulle spéculative et tout peut
pas exploser est-ce qu'on peut pas vivre
sans finalement alors non seulement on
doit vivre un peu mais revoit vivre sans
ouais parce que ça moi alors s'ils
voulaient le deuxième aspect une fois
qu'on a expliqué les choses une fois du
monde se rencontrent je pense que le
plus important car je prendre un peu de
hauteur mais c'est de comprendre que
nous en france et en europe nous ne
dépendons que des américains en matière
numérique alors j'ose je faisais un
petit mot je me suis dit j'avais pas le
faire je vais me faire engueuler par
matt équipe mais c'est pas très grave on
parle beaucoup de grands remplacement
aujourd'hui moi je vous dis une chose le
grand remplacement numérique il est déjà
là il est déjà là parce que les
américains en fait produisent les
technologies que nous utilisons les
gouvernent aujourd'hui notre monde qui
ne ne progressent que par la technologie
le grand place nécessaire dans leur
essence 1 d'ailleurs oui mais voilà
exactement point de vue sémantique non
mais oui c'est ça le sujet l'un sujet
c'est qu'on devrait avoir des politiques
qui qui nous permette de vivre heureux
sans d'investir dans les entreprises
européennes y en a aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui marc van der berg le patron
de facebook est il et il est dans quel
état guinée il est confiant où il est
illégal mais c'est un robot ce petit
boulet que j'annule au sénat il est
comme ça il bouge pas c'est ce mec perd
rien tout glisse sur lui tout glissions
us à faire que c'est l'action d'ailleurs
vous parliez de l'action des raisons il
a perdu blédard jeu mental mais à chaque
fois qu'il a perdu il ya tout de suite
regard up l'action est à son image mais
milliards il ya un an il a perdu sa
mairie de meaux
dans quelques temps fait rien on le sait
pas donc pas ses auteurs parce que des
révélations aussi d'une ancienne de
france oui oui dernièrement à la voile à
kaka aussi hélas l'action commencé déjà
baissé continue il a une mauvaise
séquence c'est qu'entre semaine europe
mais il veut rappeler 2018 mais où des
millions de données était partie
exploitée pour
bridge antsika pour la campagne du
royaume uni et il est sorti de ça alors
ça aurait dû être la fin de facebook moi
j'adore facebook bah oui mais vous
adorez le service oui j'adorais parce
que il ya plein de gens qui comptent
faire de même c'est bien j'aime bien
facebook donc et ça ne vous inquiète pas
son une société qui dépendent que soient
les américains les européens et chinois
ou tout ce que vous voulez on est une
société qui n'est pas entièrement d'une
prise qui est faux
[Rires]
oui il ya 15 ans encore et quand tu
quand il faisait quand y avait une panne
il faisait des enfants maintenant il
capte une panne il suicide voile et je
crois qu'il est
gay il part de ses bons c'est mon mari
est à noter